the law found that there was no
collusion this is what became is just
based on the premise of here Donald
Trump big is above the law
none of us think that he's above the law
someone is innocent until proven guilty
whether it's the president whether it's
an officer or whether it's some kid in a
red hat being screamed down by black
Hebrew Israelites who think white people
all go to hell again question the day do
you think Donald Trump should be
impeached do you think he will be
impeached what's the over-under john
albert has made a video about this a
video he did a show about it and they
always get they always go viral and i
don't entirely nurse it funny but these
segments aren't right so let's just use
it as a springboard here to get into
impeachment and what that would look
like what would be required and why it
makes very little sense let's see how
strong the cases we have a first appear
from john oliver talking about
impeachment we're gonna focus on
something getting talked about a lot
these days
impeachment ever since this president
got elected people have been dying to
see him impeached not everyone say
everybody i would show the blind by the
way before we get started i gotta say
john oliver really good at taking what
should be a three minute segment and
stretching it out not any points without
any other undergirding sources and
honestly i will say this for all of our
criticism of vox at least they just make
up sources half-asian bill that's a big
reason you're here today because i think
this is right in your wheelhouse but
let's go to is his next clip John Oliver
they think that you get impeached you're
gone and that is completely not true
it's not the means to the end that
people think all you do vote to impeach
Bye Bye Birdie that's a great show
there's a show the show it's like early
morning you know you didn't have cable
you'd watch them she's right she's
absolutely right here yeah and John
Oliver later goes on to admit that but
all right paper-thin 20 minutes segment
we're going is there anything they kind
of come here is how the impeachment
process works typically it begins with
an inquiry in the House of
Representatives to arrange a committee
investigates and holds hearings into a
pressure majority decides they found
impeachable offenses they vote to
impeach but that is not the end that
merely moves the process to the Senate
where a trial is held and the president
is only removed from office if a
two-thirds majority votes for that so
what is the case for putting this
president through that process
next teach us about conjunctions and
their functions dare you please you
bring in a bad memories but it's you do
have to have the votes in the house but
yeah people Democrats notably Pelosi
arguably the most powerful Democrat in
the party they don't support it no and
you don't you seen a majority like that
you need two-thirds majority in the
Senate where Republicans have a majority
well by the way in the notification bell
because apparently subscriptions don't
mean anything join up at mug club we
appreciate it everyone who has an iTunes
for those who have not now yesterday
night Tunes everything he said sample so
he's right so I mean you have to
analogize it to it like maybe the
criminals the criminal sphere where you
have a grand jury the prosecutor goes in
front of a jury side and we even bring
charges that's what the house is there's
an initial investigation even before
that so then you take it to the floor of
the house the house decides by a
majority are you gonna actually issue
articles of impeachment you draw them up
you have done you vote then that's when
the rest of the trial happens so what
typically you would call the trial and
the trial the jury members are the
Senators so you've got a supermajority
you've got to do there so that is right
it's three investigation articles trial
sounds a lot of work can we just get
just get Co me in there pretty pretty
much all right apply next clip one area
where we already have considerable
evidence against Trump is obstruction of
justice Ribera serious allegation it was
among the articles of impeachment it is
a serious and it is and Clinton
obstruction was also half of Robert
Mueller's report it is a serious
allegation that's why you made it it
would be a serious allegation for me to
accuse you of rape you rapist proof and
he's right by the way that both Nixon
and Clinton had articles
I'm obviously a Nixon resigned but
partly because of obstruction so
understood but that's what a comparison
of Nixon and Clinton with Donald Trump
ends why
what could let me ask you what could
possibly be the difference between Nixon
Clinton and Donald Trump why is one not
like the other they committed a crime
they were actually guilty big difference
Watergate did happen Clinton did commit
perjury lying about in turn sexes yeah
all the sexes oh all the interns that's
just the one we chose to poorly and this
is one thing I don't know how there can
be obstruction if there isn't an
underlying crime there's right would
have to be a corrupt motive think about
it for a second second I want to go to a
half-asian bill on this yeah two key
words obstruction and justice I'm just
gonna go by the legal dictionary from
Cornell are they reputable Cornell I
assume Cornell is a good University all
right okay obstruction cousin impeding
stopping block justice a concept of
fairness or moral rightness in this case
as it relates to a ruling of finding
okay so we know President Donald Trump
didn't commit any collusion right so in
this case what would Justice what would
be justice the conclusion that no
collusion occurred what a Trump do he
screaming he yelled yes he drew tantrums
over the fact that no collusion occurred
sting justice yeah and the AG even said
and I know we're gonna get to it
probably in a second but the age he said
there wasn't enough evidence well he
said yeah it's for being with corrupt
motives your motives are that you're
innocent that's actually from from ball
yeah there you go see that in and also
the the deputy AG said not enough
evidence like these are two of the
brightest minds in legal jurisprudence
not edges in John Oliver I think we have
more cut we have more clips to get like
I said paper-thin here's why this really
matters but for Don McGann trunk might
have stopped an investigation into
himself and if a president can shut down
an investigation he can basically do
anything with no consequences it's a big
deal exactly even one Trump was innocent
Democrats fourthly taxpayer to spend two
years thirty five million dollars
invested couldn't even
everybody's Nazi pharaohs but I doubt
that he goes on to talk about the sort
of the precedent I guess he doesn't use
the word if I'm not mistaken that it
sets the next clip to be honest the
thing that's tipped us all now is being
honest not opening an inquiry comes with
consequences too because it essentially
sends the message that the president can
act with impunity which is a dangerous
precedent on a second what message that
the left are now guilty until proven
innocent unless you're a black guy
waving an accurate scale rap with a gun
at passers-by in the park I get it it's
just they're different strokes if an
investigation finds the nothing this is
what this is the message that's been
sent are you talking about the message
that would be sent here ed Donald Trump
stop the investigation or a message that
is sent right now is that Democrats the
left will destroy you there will be a
widow hunt it doesn't matter if you're
innocent it doesn't matter what you've
done we've learned that I'm Cavanaugh
Covington kids all Trump supporters
who've been tarred and feathered is
racist Jesse smaller let's go to the
next clip don't juniors failure to alert
the FBI when Russia offered them Intel
join the campaign and his response was
appalling
shouldn't he are going to the FBI when
he got daddy okay somebody comes up and
says hey I have information on your
opponent do you call the FBI I don't
think I mean from night one you do I've
seen a lot of things over in my life I
don't think in my whole life I've ever
called the FBI
it's in my whole life I don't you don't
call the FBI this is somebody that said
how many people laughing you called the
FBI call the FBI that's what should
happen the FBI director is wrong so much
in that no your honor the defense is
wrong
here's first off no info changed hands
okay now here's the crazy part this is
something that no one again it says
predicated the impeachment on because
there's no no collusion right there
hasn't been any proof of obstruction so
now it's wahala second maybe there was
information exchanges
when people talk about Trump jr. meeting
with the Russians the Russians they met
with work for fusion GPS to create the
hoax steal that's yet very our we know
that for a fact
so Oliver is in disbelief that Trump
didn't call the FBI about the Russians
offering dirt but Hillary couldn't
actually paid you
work up those Russians to create a fake
dossier to influence the election I I'm
it is amazing to me that it hasn't been
covered more do you notice that if
anything bad happens it comes back to
they blame it on pret on President Trump
and listen I listen okay let me guys
okay he's an Isis biggest Crimea well
you rug okay
the FBI sucks we get it like kind of a
dick but he's not guilty of these crimes
two things can be true at once right it
is remarkable to me that we are talking
and this is what they blame it on Trump
that people have lost faith in the
institutions of America institutions
like the FBI gosh no you know why
because we see that they can be used as
political weapons that's the issue why
don't we talk about the problem rather
than the fact that Donald Trump is a
bullish Li complaining about a valid
problem
the defense is wrong I think we have one
last clip here Harold Dean Israel I
can't guarantee that impeachment will
work out the way that you want it to
because it probably won't but that
doesn't mean that it's not worth doing
because if nothing else we'd be standing
by the basic fundamental principle that
nobody is above the law and in doing so
it would mean that when people tell
dying relatives that we're doing
everything we can to hold this president
accountable at least this time it would
actually be true know what you would be
saying is that the rule of law doesn't
matter that someone isn't innocent until
proven guilty that no one is above the
law he's not above the law the law found
that there was no collusion this is what
became is just based on the premise of
here Donald Trump is above the law none
of us think that he's above the law no
one in this room by the way I don't
think anyone here the Hillary Clinton
voter I don't know no one in this room
thinks that President Trump is above the
law that's not what we're saying we are
saying is just like the covenant kids
just like Jesse Smollett just like all
the hate crime hoaxes that we've gone
through this last year does almost all
of the black lives matter crumbs that
turned out to be hoaxes someone is
innocent until proven guilty whether
it's the president whether it's an
officer or whether it's some kid in a
red hat being screamed down by black
Hebrew Israelites who think white people
all go to hell that's reasonable yeah it
might not work out as you hope but we
have to okay first off I don't agree
with the second part right do do at that
first part you're right it might not end
up as the left hopes let's go through it
walk it through ok best
scenario Trump gets removed and you get
president pence I don't know if you
enjoyed this video click one of these
other videos in these boxes
subscribe to the channel at the
notification bell and join Mudd Club at
lot of credit comm / Mudd Club is the
only way we keep this kind of content
going on YouTube since we've been
entirely demonetised recently which is
fine we'll be ok